[Music]
welcome back to harbor unbox today we
have the new g-force our Tex 2080 super
on hand for testing I'll keep that still
so doesn't reflect all over the place
anyway
following the release of the 2060 super
and the 2070 super we now have the final
piece of Nvidia's super puzzle so what
is the most super of the supers got in
store for us not a lot to be honest
coming in at the same $700 u.s. MSRP as
the original 2080 it has just two extra
SM units enabled for a four percent
increase in cause this means we're now
seeing fully enabled
tu-104 silicon the same silicon use by
the standard RT x 2080 as well as the 27
t helping to make that upgrade a little
less pointless is a nine percent
frequency uplift for the base clock
which works out to be just a six percent
increase for the boost clock and due to
the way GPU boost works that will
probably end up being three to four
percent at the most the GT dr6 memory
frequency has also been increased now
we're looking at a peak data transfer
speed of fifteen point five gigabits per
second up from fourteen gigabits per
second so an eleven percent improvement
in memory performance these upgrades
have increased the tgp rating by sixteen
percent going up from 215 watts to 250
watts Nvidia says the our TX 2080 super
delivers a robust 4k experience along
with real-time array tracing but for
this video we're going to look at the 4k
gaming experience while skipping over a
road tracing for now is our opinion on
the technology at least in its current
state hasn't really changed since Tim
covered it in detail many months ago Tim
does plan to produce a rate racing
roundup content piece sort of an updated
look at rate racing with the super
graphics card soon so if you're
interested in the technology that will
no doubt be worth a watch anyway that's
enough talking about specs let's just go
over the test systems set up and then
we'll get into the benchmark results for
testing I've used an Intel Core I 919 a
hurricane cloaked at 5 gigahertz with 32
gigabytes of ddr4 3400 memory and the
graphics card used to test each GPU can
be found in the video description the
latest drivers avail
at the time of testing had been used and
all data is up to date we have 13 games
to look at before the usual performance
breakdowns and cost per frame data and
again I'll be focusing on 4k performance
but for all the 1080p and 1440p results
please get them over for free on our
patreon page the link is in the video
description ok let's get into the
results first up we have the newest game
added to our battery of benchmarks F 1
2019 here we see the 2080 Super
delivering 75 FPS on average making it
drumroll please 4 percent faster than
the standard 20 80 and 17% slower than
the 2080 Ti
thankfully the margin is a little more
noteworthy in battlefield 5 here we see
the new super version offered an 8
percent performance uplift over the
old-fashioned 20 80 and that basically
put it on par with the now-discontinued
Radeon 7 is just a 3% boost here to the
average framerate
over the standard 2080 though we do see
a 6 percent improvement for the 1% low
performance this time the 2080 Super was
15% slower than the TI model so can I
interest you in a 1 to 2 FPS performance
gain well good because that's all you're
going to get in Metro Exodus and that
equated to a 4% performance boost pretty
much what we're expecting though given
the specs
well here's cause for celebration a 6
percent performance boost in resident
evil 2 taking us to 66 FPS on average at
4k for some nice smooth gameplay we
weren't quite able to hit the 60fps
sweet spot in shut off the Tomb Raider
but given the 20 ATT I just fall short
of that it's not particularly surprising
the extra memory bandwidth does allow
the 2080 Super to beat the vanilla 2080
by a rather impressive 11% margin in
this title so there is that memory
bandwidth though isn't that important in
fortnight so here we see just a measly
three percent performance uplift over
the standard 2084 72 FPS on average at
4k still it was a nice smooth and very
crisp looking gaming experience here we
see just another 2 FPS gained this time
when testing with the division 2 and
that provided us with a 4% performance
boost over the standard r-tx 2080 hold
on to your horses here we have
a 3 FPS performance boost if you ignore
the 1% low result and that allows us to
get a breathtaking 4 percent performance
uplift sorry about the sarcasm guys this
script really wasn't that easy to write
moving on to Forza horizon 4 and life
shut off the Tomb Raider this is a game
that does benefit from some extra memory
bandwidth at the 4k resolution so here
we see a 7 percent performance boost
taking the 20 80 super to 92 FPS on
average we also see a 6 percent
performance boost in Far Cry new dawn
which allowed the 20 80 super to just
edged out the Radeon 7 then the second
last game tested is World War Z and here
the 20 80 super provided a 4 percent
performance improvement over the
standard 2080 that pretty much been the
story of this review finally we have
Assassin's Creed Odyssey 4 a 3 FPS
performance uplift though that did
equate to a 6 percent increase in
framerate but I think we're pretty well
done here so let's move on to the power
consumption and then operating
temperatures first up we have GPU only
power consumption and here the 2080
super is reported to consume 5 percent
more power than the standard r-tx 2080
which sounds right given the specs that
we just saw this means it consumed 6
percent less power than the Radeon 7 but
24 percent more than the new 5700 XT
moving on we have total system
consumption which is measured from the
wall and here we see the faster 2080
super increased total draw by 12 percent
over the standard 2080 there are a few
reasons for this increase the GDD are 6
memory will be consuming more power
given the 11 percent overclock and the
CPU will also be working slightly harder
given the small increase in performance
also what's quite interesting is that
the 2080 super does push total system
consumption higher than that of the
Radeon 7je here's a look at the
operating temperatures and clock speeds
I'm not going to waste time overclocking
this thing as with all cheering GPUs
you're likely looking at about a 10%
performance boost when manually
overclocking so due to very limited time
I'll save all that testing for well any
AIB testing that I might do anyway the
founders edition model maxed out at just
72 degrees in a 21 degree room and there
it maintained a core clock speed of 1900
and 5 megahertz with a fan speed of
1,800
20 rpm making this graphics card rather
cool and quiet after an hour-long f1
2019 stress test well that all seemed
pretty underwhelming but given the specs
we were really ever only going to be in
for an underwhelming ride the r-tx 2080
super looks to be the least super
graphics card from nvidia in some time
but before I get too bummed out with
what we've just seen with this release
let's just go over some before words
breakdown graphs and then of course the
cost per frame data okay so on average
the 2080 Super was 5% faster than the
standard 2080 and that certainly sounds
right given what we just saw for testing
I was using the MSI r-tx 2080 juke which
comes with a modest overclock that sees
that maintain a clock speed of nineteen
hundred and five megahertz under load
and that's the same operating
frequencies the twenty eighty super efi
card for those gaming at 1440p on
average you're looking at a six percent
performance uplift so very similar to
what we saw at 4k not much more to go
over here so let's move on to our
comparison with the r-tx 20 atti here we
see that on average the twenty eighty
super was 16% slower when compared to
the 20 80 TI not a massive difference
and it is around 30% cheaper so if
you're not after the most premium 4k
experience possible the twenty eighty
super looks to be a decent option then
for those gaming at 1440p the 20 80 TI
looks to be a bit of a waste as the 2080
Super was just 12% slower on average and
never more than 19% slower
worst case then when compared to the
Radeon rx 5700 XT the 2080 Super was on
average 26 % faster at 4k but given it
cost 75% more and was never more than
45% faster you'll have to decide if
paying that kind of price premium for
the ability to run a slightly higher
quality settings is worth it then for
those of you getting at 1440p the 2080
Super is an even less attractive option
as it was just 17% fast and the 5,700
exit a on average so that being the case
let's move on to check out the cost per
frame data starting with the MSRP
comparison using the 4k gaming data we
see that the 2080 Super comes out at a
cost of 9 dollars and 85 cents per frame
given it comes at the same 700
MSRP as the original 2080 that makes it
roughly 6% cheaper per frame then
compared to the 5700 XT you are paying
41 percent more per frame which is a
massive price premium but I guess that's
just what you're facing right now and
going up a level in performance however
the 1440p results are less favorable
again looking strictly at MSRP s we see
that the 2080 super costs 5 dollars and
73 cents per frame and that made at 5%
cheaper than the standard RT x 2080 that
said it's also 52% more costly than the
5700 XT per frame so unless you need to
go from around 106 FPS on average to 122
fps the radeon GPU is a much more
sensible purchase but what about current
market pricing well here the new 2080
Super doesn't look nearly as good
largely due to the recently discounted
outgoing RT X 2080 graphics card which
has dropped down to 630 dollars u.s. at
least for some models whereas the 2080
Super was 6% cheaper per frame compared
to the standard 2080 when looking at the
MSRP it's now 5 percent more expensive
when comparing current market price we
see the exact same thing we're looking
at the 1440p data the 2060 Super
currently cost six percent more than the
2080 per frame and that's because it
costs 11% more overall but only provided
5% more performance okay so earlier this
month we got the 2070 Super and the 2060
Super 2070 Super provided 12% more
performance than the standard model but
with a 50% price cut to the standard
model the 2070 Super was only a fraction
better in terms of cost per frame but I
suppose that's better than nothing the
2060 super on the other hand pretty well
gave us nothing it costs 18% more than
the standard 2060 and was just 8% faster
on average so 9 percent more costly per
frame and we're now seeing a similar
story with the 2080 Super but here the
performance lift is even less exciting
in short the r-tx 2080 Super it isn't a
bad product it's just not a particularly
good one either or at least it's not
very exciting pattern videos simply just
discounted the art 620 80 to $600
that would have been worlds more
exciting and
my opinion but whatever now we have more
cheering based graphics cards as a side
note I should also just point out that
the our checks twenty eighty super was
just nine percent faster on average than
the GTX 1082 I at both 1440p and 4k so
another way to look at this is we're
getting a nine percent performance
uplift at the exact same price point
almost two and a half years later
boy oh boy the RX 50 850 900 series
can't get here soon enough and on that
note I am done with this one if you
enjoyed the video please give it a like
it really wasn't easy to talk about four
to five percent performance gains over
and over again so feel free to show some
support by hitting that like button and
if you would like to support the channel
more directly while also receiving some
cool perks such as access to our
exclusive just go chat and monthly live
streams which we'll be doing next Monday
then go check out our patreon page the
links in the video description and as
always thank you for watching I'm your
host Steve and I'll see you again next
time
[Music]